(upbeat music)
- We did it people, we actually
made it to the end of 2020
and what a year it was.
Despite the plague, the
draconian authoritarian
perpetual lockdowns and
riots in the streets,
I was still able to
continue the show,
launch my first book, do
tons of media appearances
and connect with some
old and some new friends.
It was great to be on the
other side of the interview
with people like Tucker
Carlson, Candace Owens,
Bryan Callen, Ben
Shapiro, Jordan Belfort,
Michael Knowles,
and many others.
My team put together
a few segments
from my favorite media
appearances of 2020.
In a year which really
upped the crazy,
I hope I added just a little bit
of sanity amidst the madness.
I wish you guys Merry
Christmas, happy holidays,
a happy new year and I look
forward to continuing to make
some sense of a world gone mad.
See you in 2021, barring
a meteor hitting the earth
in the next few days,
which probably will happen.
Now take a look at some of
my favorite media moments
from 2020.
Your whole life,
your whole story
for all the good
and the tough times
and everything else is a
perfect example of what
in a strange sense of what
America is supposed to be.
Right?
You create stuff,
you don't turn to the
government to do anything.
That doesn't mean
there wasn't a time
when the government
could do some stuff
and was better at
doing some stuff.
The government at one time
did get us to the moon.
- I was gonna use
that exact thing.
- But who's getting us to Mars?
It's Elon Musk.
- Exactly.
- If you're a great
scientist, right now,
like you're a great mind,
you're a young person,
you're a great mind,
great scientist.
Do you want a government job?
That's why the worship of Fauci
is a really interesting thing.
Look, he's a scientist.
I'm not sitting here
besmirching the guy,
but in effect, great scientists
go for other jobs now.
There's financial
reasons for it.
There's freedom reasons for it.
You just get trapped
in this machine.
But really what you're
talking about is do you-
- He's a functionary.
He's just a functionary,
Fauci, right?
A government-
- Every month he
says something else.
Don't wear masks, wear masks.
Lock downs, don't do anything,
they do things.
- I'm not a Fauci fan.
At this point though I
think you have to feel,
okay, I get it, buddy.
You have to be basking in
the glow of this thing.
He's loving it.
He's just saying shit.
He's like almost like Trump.
You never know what's gonna
come out of Fauci's mouth.
You know what?
Sorry guys, just do
what you're told.
This shit that this guy says,
an unelected official
is almost unbelievable.
- I know.
- You go, Fauci.
You just keep saying
stupid shit, go ahead.
- Well, it's like, well,
because people say,
"But you got to believe the
science, the scientists."
Believe the scientists.
That makes no sense.
I mean, you know that science-
- Exactly.
- Science is not perfection.
- You know, like science-
- Basic science is not
to believe science,
it's try to challenge every
hypothesis and improve on,
the way you see if
something's true or false is
by testing it and challenging
it and it evolves over time.
I was a science, a bio
major, biochem in college,
I have a degree
and most of the stuff I
was taught is not true.
I had false beliefs.
I'm like, well, you know, the
brain can't grow new cells.
And I was taught that
and it's not true.
- Yeah and that's the
purpose of science, right?
You see a theory and you
try to, you either prove it
or you disprove it
or whatever else
but we put these phrases,
believe in science.
The same people that
say believe in science
will also tell you
that you're allowed
to select your gender.
- Right.
- So it's like I'm
not a scientist
but I'm pretty sure having
a penis makes you male
and having a vagina
makes you female.
- Preference of sex
is a different issue.
- You could prefer whatever
the hell you want to prefer.
And by the way, you
could also transition
but that doesn't
change your biology
and saying that doesn't
make you anti-trans.
If someone's trans, if someone
is born biologically male
and then transitions to
become female effectively,
they're not
biologically a female.
That's just the truth.
- Questions, so I think
we it's interesting
we agree on so many different
things in the sense like-
- Long Island creates a
certain sense of reality.
I really think so.
- It's almost like a
practical way of thinking
that I buy into where
like for instance,
Do you think it's
fair that girls
that transition are
winning all the medals now
in women's sports?
Like what do you think?
- You mean boys that
transitioned to females
that are then beating the
crap out of all these?
- Yes.
- No, of course it's not.
But now you've got the
feminists saying that's okay.
- But it's not, it's
obviously just not.
- Yeah, it's just not.
- Nothing against the girls.
I'm not saying you should
have a separate league
for all the trans people
that want to compete
against each other because it's-
- By the way, I'd be okay
with that if they want that.
- Whatever it's because it's
just a different musculature.
It's obvious.
You know what it seems like?
It seems that like, again,
I always say it's on both sides
but right now it's whoever we
really is out in full force.
It's like they
ignore the obvious.
Like they say things that
go against the obvious-ness
of life and general
common sense.
And they try to justify it by
shouting you down with labels
and identity politics.
And if you don't agree
with them, you're evil.
You're this, you're
that, you're evil.
- You know, Dave, you
and I are a lot of like.
I might be slightly
better looking
but we share same
common interests.
And I don't know
if I'm overreacting
with this chaos, but
I think you and I
both recently joined
a special club.
Wasn't the mile high club
but it was a special club.
Care to explain?
- Greg, I suspect you're
not talking about the club
that owns this book, "The Plus",
which is one of the
best reads of the year.
- Why, thank you.
- I think you're talking
about another club,
which is the gun owners club
and yeah, we both did.
And look, I've only
lived in New York
and now I live in Los Angeles.
I've only lived in
these two crazy places,
but after watching what has
gone on for the last two months
in America, you'd actually
have to be bananas
to not at least strongly
consider taking your protection
of your family and your
property into your own hands.
I mean, we're watching mobs
not only burn down stores
and break windows and
attack people on the streets
but literally stop cars in
the middle of the street.
You saw what happened
to the McCloskey family
who had to defend their
property in Missouri.
There's all sorts
of stuff here that
as American citizens we
have the God-given right
that is enshrined in
the Bill of Rights
which is still a
pretty great document.
The Second Amendment, which
is the right to bear arms
and protect yourself
and you and I are doing
what you're supposed
to do as an American.
If they're gonna
defund the police,
well then I'm gonna
defend myself.
- So never have I had
less faith in the media
to bring us any element of
truth on this sort of stuff.
But where do you come
down on, you know,
you have a whole chapter in here
about how to spot fake news.
What does your media diet
consist of these days?
I mean, I assume you still
read the New York Times
even though it's
labeled both of us
gateways to the Nazi party.
(Dave laughing)
- Yes. Yes.
It's a seminal moment in my life
when my dad went to
get a bagel and coffee
at the same place
he does every Sunday
for the last 40 years
and someone had to bring
the New York Times up to him
and say, "Oh, I didn't
know David was the leader
of the alt-right."
Was a really wonderful moment.
Well, I'll tell you this,
just in the last couple days,
the New York Times did a
story on misinformation
in the age of coronavirus.
And they talked about
a tweet that went viral
and a bunch of people we know,
Steven Crowder and Brit Hume,
a few other people
tweeted this article.
The article was eventually
taken down by Medium,
not by the author who
was analyzing data.
It was taken down by Medium.
And they talk about how
this is misinformation
because he wasn't being
alarmist about coronavirus.
I happen to know the author.
It's a guy by the
name of Aaron Ginn,
I think he's a decent fellow.
I retweeted the article
because I thought
in a time when it's
almost impossible to know
who's telling the truth,
I think it's important
that we all hear different
perspectives on things.
So they include
me in this chart,
showing that when I tweeted it,
it really started going viral.
And it's all about
misinformation.
So I screenshot it
and I put it up.
And I didn't even tag the author
from the New York Times
'cause I don't even bother
tagging these people anymore
because as you know,
they're not journalists,
they're quote
unquote journalists.
I didn't even tag the
guy, but he wrote back
and said something like we
didn't quote mention you.
You were just in a graph
but I'm glad you think
you're flattered.
And I thought it's this exact
type of glib doublespeak
that is exactly, this is what
I said to him on Twitter.
I mean, that you guys are
destroying your own profession.
You're telling me when
you put my name in a chart
in an article about
misinformation
that's not mentioning me.
It's not mentioning me.
And of course, if you
Google the definition
of the word mentioned, it
qualifies as a mention,
but what's happening
right now is all I ask.
I tweet this all the time.
All the media has to do,
you want to shut up Ben Shapiro?
You want to stop
scary Dave Rubin?
You know what you do?
You start behaving honestly,
but they can't do it.
The ship has sailed.
The thing that is the New
York Times is just the shell
of the New York Times
with a bunch of progressive
activists underneath it.
I know someone that you know too
that works at the
New York Times,
who although I don't
think this person's
talking to me anymore,
would often tell me
about horrifically woke
the entire newsroom had become
and that there's nothing
even remotely close
to true coming
out of that place.
They don't even
have an ombudsman.
Ombudsman, is that the word?
- Yep.
- Yeah.
They don't even, yeah,
they didn't even have
an ombudsman anymore
which is the person who's
supposed to be fact checking
the fact checkers in effect.
A public editor, they don't
even have that anymore.
It is propaganda.
CNN is propaganda.
I'll give you a real
good example of this.
In December, I
missed you by a day,
but we both spoke at the Turning
Point Student Action Summit
event in West Palm Beach.
And the day that I spoke,
I spoke that morning,
Trump spoke that afternoon and
I had never heard Trump speak
in real time before,
in real life.
And we're watching the speech
and I was actually
in the second row
and you know, it's
Trump, he goes up there,
he's half standup comic,
he's getting the crowd
going, the whole thing.
And then he says
this thing about,
and he gives an hour
and a half speech
at it's half prompter,
half off the cuff.
And he says, this
thing about wind power.
And he goes, "I love wind power.
Nobody knows more about
wind power than me.
I've studied wind
power my whole life."
And then he goes on
and on about wind power
back to the script.
But that line obviously,
those few lines were
obviously improv.
And I turned to
David and I said,
"I bet you that within an hour,
there's going to be an article
about how Trump
says he knows more
about wind power than anybody
and he studied it
his whole life."
And then voila, all
the articles come out,
Donald Trump says
he knows more about
wind power than anyone.
And it's like, man, you idiots.
He was joking.
And then actually made
some interesting points
about the validity of wind power
and how important it
should be or should not be.
And then linked that also to
failed other green projects
that we've done like Solyndra
and a whole bunch
of other stuff.
Anyway, so where do
I get my diet from?
It's very difficult.
I think you guys at the Daily
Wire are doing a nice job.
I think TheBlaze is
doing a nice job.
I do occasionally read some
things out of the Times
and the Washington Post,
but they're pretty crappy.
I try to pay attention.
You know what?
I basically try to do
is on Twitter I follow
a multitude of people from
different perspectives
and I try to just whittle that
into something that's true.
But I think one of the
saving graces for me
which is why I
don't envy the guys
that have to do the
grind every day,
the hours and hours
of content every day
is that it's really hard.
It's hard to distill truth
out of this madness
all the time.
And I think you do a
pretty damn good job of it
but it is not easy to do.
It's not a fun word.
- It's a fun word.
Who wants to be Conservative?
- Right? So both of the, right.
- Liberal sounds fun.
- Does liberal
sound fun anymore?
All the words have
become so tainted now
that like, but
that was really why
I wrote the book because
it was the idea is
think for yourself.
If there are 10
important issues,
there's obviously
more than that,
but if there were
10 important issues,
if you and I agree
on six of them
and two of them we're
kind of still figuring out
and two of them we
absolutely disagree on,
well, Candace, I
still want to live
in the same country as you.
I still want to be your friend.
And that's the
thing that everyone
is just getting rid of.
- Right.
- And I'm so happy
you talked about that
because I totally agree with you
that the puritan
conservatism doesn't work.
And I think that I've actually
tried to get rid of that
and I've dealt with it a lot.
I mean, you saw me literally,
I feel like I've
grown up politically
in front of everybody.
And I dealt with that a lot-
- You've done that
more than anybody,
maybe even more than me
because when I started,
I was starting from like
a political base, right?
Like I was on the left,
I was on the Young Turks.
I was a progressive.
And then I started waking up
but my base was
kind of political.
I was a political science major.
I always cared about this.
That first time you
walked into my studio
as you said before,
you were kind of
totally figuring it out.
- I was open.
And I was open to listening
and I never wanted
to be the person
that pretended to be
someone that I wasn't,
if I wasn't comfortable
answering a question,
I would say this
is my feeling on it
but I don't really know
much about it so that's it.
And it was great.
Honestly, I always tell people
that was such a good moment
for me to be on your show
because you were so
accepting of that.
You were like you don't need
to commit to this or this
and have an answer right now.
And I actually ironically
had the opposite experience
when I went on Joe
Rogan, where I was like,
I feel like there's
something more,
like I don't trust
the climate change.
And he's like, "You need
to pick or be agnostic."
And I was like, I just, my
feeling is that it's not right
because I was told
I was gonna die
when I was in high school
because of climate change
and I'm still here, but
I haven't researched it.
- That's 'cause
you're a survivor.
- I haven't researched it.
And I felt like he wanted me
to pick one camp or the other.
And so what I've tried to do,
even in being a
Conservative is be more open
and especially on
the pro-choice stuff
because I say to people, my
friends have gotten abortions.
People that I've grown up
with have gotten abortions.
And I know if they didn't
go to the abortion clinic
saying I want to kill a baby,
in fact, I know that
they learned in school
that it was a clump
of cells, right?
So how can you, then we
have to be warmer, right?
In saying, how about
saying, you know what?
Even if you got an abortion,
you can still be pro-life.
And that is a stance that I take
because it's less
black and white.
It's less you killed a
baby, you're a murderer.
That doesn't work.
That's the same kind
of stuff the left does
on the other side.
If I believe in my position
and I do, that it's a life,
how about saying to them
I know that it can be very
confusing when you're young
and you're told that your
whole life's gonna get ruined
if you get pregnant, it's
just a clump of cells
and you couldn't make a decision
but you can change your mind.
- There's so much there.
So first off, partly why
the left is always screaming
is they don't know really
what their starting point is.
So people on the
right, generally,
if you're an American, you
believe in individual rights,
you believe that
every single person
regardless of their skin color
or sexuality or gender,
blah, blah, blah
should have the
same exact rights.
On the left, you sort
of have this idea
that the state is kind of
supposed to do a lot of stuff
and then the disagreement
is how much it should do.
So the best way I
can explain this is
if you think back to
the 2016 election,
it was like, if you picture
Marco and Cruz and
Trump all up there,
they didn't have massive
substantive issues.
They had issues about
personality, right?
So Trump was your little
Marco and your lion Ted
and you're this one
and blah, blah, blah.
But they sort of all
believe in the Constitution.
They all believe that
America is fundamentally good
and the rest of it.
If you look at where
the Democrats have been
for the last couple years,
it's like they kind of
don't really believe
in the Constitution,
all the time they
kind of tell you that,
they never say words
like freedom and liberty.
Imagine if someone
walked on stage
at one of those things
and said the word freedom,
people would be like, you're
at the wrong event, buddy.
What are you talking about here?
But I think that gets to
why they're so hysterical
all the time because
they have this idea
that the state is
supposed to do a lot.
And then the next guy is like,
no, the state should do more.
And then you're kind of
like, oh, maybe it should,
otherwise I'm a bad guy.
So it's like when they say
they're for $15 minimum wage
and then Rashida
Tlaib comes along,
that's Bernie's been
pushing 15 forever
which is a horrible
idea on so many levels
and antithetical
to American ideas
because why should the
government be able to force
a private company what
to do and put that aside.
But then Rashida comes
along and she's like, no,
it should be 20.
And it's like, well,
she'd kind of right
because you just
made up a number
so why not make
up another number.
- Why can't she?
- And then somebody's
gonna come along
and go Rashida, you're
racist, it's 25.
So it's like, so they don't know
what their fundamental
principle is.
And because of that,
because of that,
that's why they're
crazy all the time.
Because constantly you're
looking around going
who's going to outdo
me on something?
And I think that's
a fundamental piece
of why having a
debate about abortion,
which I've tried to
do a million times.
Lila Rose, who've you had
her on this show, right?
So she's been on my show.
I think she's wonderful.
Obviously we have some
disagreements on this stuff.
I have put out there
many times on Twitter
I would love to have
a pro-choice advocate
come on the show with Lila Rose.
We've invited Alyssa
Milano and the collection
of usual suspects,
totally respectfully,
we've reached out publicly
and privately, nobody, nobody,
and there's a reason for it.
It's not just that
Dave Rubin is mean
or something like that
or that Lila's a liar
or something like that.
These are not true
statements obviously.
It's that they don't want to
actually debate these things
in a calm way because
they need the emotion
to override the argument.
So how do you beat the mob?
Well, the mob actually
preys on the fact
that people are afraid.
And I think there's a
lot of people that think,
oh, if I could just beat,
I can sit this one out.
Let me just sit this one out,
let me be quiet this time,
it'll pass, it'll pass.
It doesn't pass.
That's the thing.
They have preyed on the fact
that good people are good people
and they have used
that against us.
And it's the frog
in the boiling pot.
If you think that
your acquiescence
or that your silence
is saving you,
you're actually turning
the dial up on the pot
that you are in.
And as you know, it does not
end well for the frog, right?
Like that frog is fried
at the end of that thing.
And I think that that is
what has happened here.
And that in many ways is why
I wanted to write the book
more than anything else
because that was the idea.
It was like I don't think
that everything I present here
is the most legendary,
political idea of all time
but I think I've been
able to communicate ideas
in a good way and I've
paid the price for that.
- And there are rewards-
- Absolutely.
- Based on the
price you paid too.
- And I don't say paid the
price to get any pity points.
I don't want any pity points.
I've gotten the rewards
of that took, right?
It's awesome, it's cool.
I wake up and I'm
ready to go every day.
- How do you feel like we
can emotionally arm ourselves
for taking on backlash?
Because if we want to be great
in our lives at any stage,
any a decade of our life,
there's going to be critics,
haters, backlash, mob,
whether it's online,
offline, whatever.
What do you think we can do
emotionally to prepare for that?
Besides what I think
is the best thing
is just to do it as
often as possible
to be able to stomach it and
say, okay, I'm still alive.
I'm still here.
It didn't kill me.
It hurts, but I'm stronger.
- Well, partly it's
that, partly it's that.
Partly it's basketball
has been a theme here.
So like partly it's why did
Michael Jordan practice harder
than anybody else?
Right? Like that
is the known thing.
Kobe was like it too.
It's like why did they do it?
Barkley didn't love practice,
Allen Iverson famously,
"Practice!", you know?
And that's not to say
they weren't great players
but Allen Iverson
and Charles Barkley
never won championships.
And Michael Jordan
won six championships
and he was in the
final six times, right?
And he's systematically
eliminated every one
of his peers to get there.
So partly it's just that
you got to, you know,
Douglas Murray who
I've had on my show,
who is a brilliant
Conservative political thinker
from the UK and one of
the greatest writers
that I think we have
in modern times.
He said to me once, he said,
"If you get in the pool,"
he said in a British accent.
"If you dip your toe in the pool
you might find out that the
water is not that cold."
And I actually think that
that's the right idea.
There's nothing to
fear, but fear itself.
It's something like that,
that we create these monsters.
And then when you
actually go ahead
and do whatever
you're supposed to do,
you might step in
the pool and be like
damn, I thought the water
was gonna be freezing
but it turns out it's 92.
- [Lewis] It's fresh,
yeah, it's fresh.
- And that's not to say
it's gonna be perfect
'cause trust me, it won't be.
You will lose friends.
I mean, we've all been
through versions of this.
People that you love
will suddenly say
the worst things about you.
I'm seeing some of this now.
I'm getting a lot of support
from my sort of
right-leaning friends.
So you know, Shapiro and
Peterson and Glenn Beck
and Dennis Prager, that crew.
A lot of my lefty guys
who had been with me
all along the road have
completely abandoned me
because they don't
want to just deal
with any of the backlash.
And I also think this
is a whole other topic
but I think that goes to a
little bit of the lefty mind
which is in constant
protection mode.
That's like sort of like
a whole separate thing
but you gotta get
in, get in the game
because the game is
coming for you anyway,
whether you, you can
say I'm not playing,
but it's what we talked
about with politics
before the game is
being played, man.
That's like saying, you know,
if we were looking
at a chess board,
it's like you are
one of the pieces
whether you like it or not.
And if the whole board
is being shifted around,
well, you got to move with it.
- They will have a journalist on
and he'll say the equivalent
of two towers, 9/11.
People died.
- These are horrible
equivalence comparisons.
- The equivalent of that
is dying every single day
and people still don't get it.
And it's like, is that
what you're saying?
And do you mind like having
some caveats around that?
How old are they?
Are we sure of that?
Are they all being tested?
There are all of these
questions where you're like,
it's almost like they want
this lockdown to go on forever.
- They do, well, first
off their ratings are up
in the midst of this because
we're all trapped at home.
So let's not, the media is dead.
I mean, that's an
important thing to just,
we have to just
say it and know it.
The mainstream media
is just absolute dead.
CNN is the WWE.
- It is.
- I mean, I think that moment
when you saw that moment
when Chris Cuomo walked out
of his basement and they said,
"Well, he's been in
quarantine for three weeks
and here he comes."
And he had the shivers
and he chipped a tooth
because he had COVID and blah.
And it's like he comes
up and he's sweating.
And then he announces, oh, it
was 'cause he was working out
downstairs while he had COVID.
The whole thing, it's all fixed.
I mean, just a week
before he had said
he was in quarantine
for three weeks,
it turns out a week
before he got into a fight
with a biker outside of
his house in the Hamptons.
- Correct and there's video.
- It's all made up nonsense.
We are watching WWE skits
in front of us and
pretending it's real.
- But why don't people get it?
- So I'm on a book
tour right now.
I have done every freaking
podcast you can think of.
I've been on every
Fox show repeatedly.
I would go on every
single CNN show,
here I'm saying it again.
I have not gotten one invite,
not one invite from MSNBC.
- They're just afraid of you.
- My only caveat
though would be,
I would only do it live
because I don't trust
them on the editing side.
But Fox, I go on live.
They don't tell me
to say anything.
I was supposed to be on
Perino right before I got here
but then this
Flynn story dropped
so they canceled me
at the last second.
- We are so polarized,
aren't we in this country,
I mean, it's just so fucking-
- Well, I think most
of us are like this.
- I think we're the
fortunate ones, don't you?
- We're fortunate in that
we're not like completely
partisan crazy people
wandering around thinking
that Nazis are hunting us down
or that half the country is
evil or something like that.
Most people aren't.
- There's really a
lot of ways to win
this presidential
election for Democrats
and it's not just getting
all those crusty white guys
in diners in the Midwest.
Nothing against guys and
diners in the Midwest.
- I swear the Trump campaign
is paying that a woman.
She's just an ad for Trump.
Dave Rubin joins us from
The Rubin Report on YouTube.
Our old friend joins
us here on set.
Dave, great to see you tonight.
- It's good to see you.
Before you say anything, Tucker,
I just want to be very clear.
The woman you're talking
about right there.
In that clip.
- Yes.
- That's Jennifer Rubin.
I am in no way related.
- I totally forgot you
had the same last name.
- Very important
that I say that.
- Well, she's a plant,
clearly she's a plant.
- What kind of
Conservative is she?
- She and Jeb Bush's former
spokeswoman who's on MSNBC,
you watch them and you're
like, you know what?
I'm voting for
Trump. I don't care.
- It's really confusing.
- It's unbelievable.
Anyway, let me ask you
how dehumanizing
do you think it is
to see people in the
media who appear intent
on dividing the country
along racial lines
to dismiss people on the
basis of their skin color?
Like how do we
get to this place?
- Who was that guy that wanted
his children not to be judged
by the color of their skin?
- There's a monument
to him, yeah.
- The content of
their character.
That guy was kind of right.
That guy, MLK Jr. Obviously,
he was a liberal,
he was a liberal
but the progressives
have nothing to do
with true liberalism.
And there's a
hilarity going on here
because for years they've
been screaming that all of us,
anyone who's not a woke
intersectional progressive
is a racist.
But what was gonna be at
the end of the road of that?
At the end of the
road is exactly
what's happening right now.
They would have to
turn it on themselves
and now they are turning
it on themselves.
So MSNBC is now putting
up people to basically say
forget those Republicans
and Conservatives
and Trump supporters
that are racist.
We're the racists because
in an hour from right now
there's gonna be a
democratic debate.
I think it's on CNN and
guess what's gonna happen?
It's gonna be all white people.
Thank God Elizabeth is
1/1,024ths Native American
or whatever it is.
I don't know what
happened to Andrew Yang.
He should be in there,
but his Asian-ness
doesn't even count, right?
Because Asian
doesn't sort of fit
into the intersectional
calculator.
So this is the end game of
what all of these competing-
- But what they're really doing
as I think you're suggesting,
if you want to be
precise about it,
they're blaming black voters.
I mean, there's a reason-
- Right, they're saying blacks
aren't supporting their own.
I mean, think how
insane that is?
- They're turning to the
African-American electorate
in the Democratic Party and
saying, "You're bigots."
Like the rich people
on MSNBC, people like,
I can't remember her name
but the woman you share
the last name with.
- Jennifer Rubin.
That's what they're doing.
- Yeah, well, you may remember
that at the State of
the Union last year
when president Trump
said we have the lowest
all-time black unemployment
and the camera's flashed to
the congressional black caucus
and they sat there like this.
Now, if you cared
about your country,
if you cared about black people
or just citizens
of your country,
wouldn't you be happy that
they have low unemployment?
That would be good.
But if you're a partisan hack
then you wouldn't
care about that.
And I think most people are
waking up to this stuff.
I mean, I sent out a
tweet at the beginning
on January 1st saying, "This
is the year of the implosion
of this thing."
- Of wokeness.
It has to implode now
because Elizabeth has to
call Bernie a misogynist
and someone else has
to call Bernie a racist
because that's all they got,
because they can't
debate on policy,
they can't really
debate on taxes
or foreign policy or
any of these things.
So they have to get you
on all of these things
because it's sort of
worked in a lot of ways
against Conservatives, right?
You're one of the few guys
that consistently stands up
against it, but it
silences a lot of people.
And I think this is
the year that it,
it just they've cried
wolf for too long.
- The polling I look at suggests
that really nobody
is for this crap
other than a very tiny
percentage of MSNBC hosts,
for example, but like
your average person
of any color doesn't
like this garbage.
- Nobody cares, it's an anathema
and it's a reverse of what
the American dream is.
Nobody cares what
your skin color is.
Nobody cares what your gender is
or even your sexuality
or any of these things.
If you're an American and you
live by the laws of America
and you work hard and and
try to better your life
and your family's life,
that's what this
whole thing is about.
But why do they never
talk about that?
Why are they afraid to say
like liberty and freedom?
Imagine that, you know
who said those words?
Tulsi Gabbard said
it, and now she's out.
- Yeah, they hate her, right.
- Yeah.
- Conservatives, we tend to
see people as individuals.
We don't see them as
black or white or gay
or a Presbyterian or Jewish.
We tend to see them
as individuals.
And I think that's a
fundamental difference.
Would that be an assessment
you would also agree to?
- Well. Yeah.
Well, it's the
fundamental difference
between say leftism
and conservatism
but it also is the most
fundamental building block
that you can have not
only for a country.
I mean, we have this in America,
this beautiful document
called the Constitution
that lays out our rights
and then the Bill of Rights,
which expands those rights.
But the government did not
give us our rights, right?
These are God-given rights.
These rights, the government
can take away your rights
but it can't give them to you.
But once you say the group
is above the individual,
you have to throw out
the individual who
dare thinks freely,
who dare takes another position.
So a very simple way I
could explain this to you
is so on an issue like abortion,
you see something right
now where the left,
which used to basically
say we're for abortion
but you can't have
abortions eight months in.
They had some
guardrails against it.
Now, of course, governor
you as a Conservative,
now you're completely
against that
and that's just fine.
But the left used to have
some semblance of a mechanism
to be able to fight its
most radical elements.
They no longer do.
So everyone on stage
right now at these debates
and Biden might be the slight
exception, slight exception.
I'm not even sure,
but these people,
they won't put an end
point on abortion.
I mean, everyone in their
right mind of course knows
that at seven months
this is a child.
This is a living being.
So this is the problem that
once you start viewing people
as the collective, you're
unable to understand
that they might have
differences with you
because you've
defined them already.
And what I would rather do
and I think Conservatives
have been very good at this
in the last couple
of years is say,
I don't care what
your sexuality is.
I don't care what your
gender is or your skin color
or the rest of it.
Do you have good ideas?
And can we work together to
hopefully create a society
that's truly tolerant for
as many people as possible?
And that's why I consistently
find myself building bridges
in places that I didn't
think would have existed
a couple of years ago.
Right now the idea of socialism
is suddenly popping up
in America which is word
genuinely the worst set
of collectivist ideas that
you could possibly ever have
that hundreds of millions
of people have died
in history under.
And it's popping up
because if you listen
to what's happening on the
left right now politically
because they've outsourced God.
Imagine if one of
those people on stage
said that they were
a real believer.
Imagine if any of them,
maybe Biden could do it.
But really the
rest of them can't.
They would never really say
that they're a believer.
Now I don't know what they are
and I wouldn't want
them to say anything
that's not true to themselves,
but they would be mocked
by everything mainstream,
everything mainstream
would mock them
the way that everything
mainstream mocks
any Christian that happens,
'cause they're
usually on the right,
they happen to be Conservatives.
But look what they're
offering us now.
Their answer is okay,
we've removed God
from the equation
and what do we get?
We get government.
And they now pray
basically to government.
They think that they
can figure out somehow
by sitting in a room with a
bunch of other politicians
and bureaucrats, the worst
sort of people that exist.
(audience laughing)
I didn't even mean that
to be funny, but actually-
(audience applauding)
I mean, but that's
what they think.
They think that they can
rejigger all of humanity
in a way that will
be so much better
than everything that
came before them.
And not only can't they,
they are going to do
the complete reverse.
So that, if for no other reason,
if for no grand revelation
or something like that
that would be a reason
to be respectful
of people that are believers,
because they can fight that in
a way that secularists can't,
the good liberals
don't have enough juice
in and of of themselves
they don't have enough juice
to fight that.
That's why liberalism
has collapsed
in the name of progressivism.
- And if you watched
the debate last night
you may have heard
a lot of this.
(everyone arguing
simultaneously)
- [Host] Senator Sanders,
we would like to
bring Mr. Steyer in
on this conversation.
- If you think that was
distracting, you are not alone.
CBS moderators have
been criticized
for quite a messy debate.
Joining me now, Dave Rubin
host of The Rubin Report
and author of the upcoming
book, "Don't Burn this Book"
and we certainly won't.
We'll have you back
to talk about that.
Fox News, when we host
debates, we use a little bell
or a little buzzer that
makes it very clear
when somebody's time is up.
They didn't have any
of that last night.
- Yeah, well, Dana, it's
always good to be with you.
You know that little
skirmish you just play there,
that little five seconds.
I mean, that was basically
the most sensible part
of the entire debate.
I mean the whole thing
is so confusing right now
because the Democratic
Party is splitting
into at least two parts
right now, perhaps more,
but at least two.
You've got sort of the
Socialist progressive lefty,
far left wing, which is the
Bernie/Elizabeth Warren wing.
And then you have the at
least slightly more moderate,
somewhat still liberal,
more blue dog Democrat,
Bernie, sorry, Mike Bloomberg
and Biden part of it.
But watching them
fray and watching
this thing go out of control,
it's like these people should
not be on stage together.
They should be separate
parties at this point.
And that's why the
fighting over each other
and the stammering and the
talking over each other.
It's like, yeah, you guys don't
have a cohesive set of ideas
that bring you
together as a party
so of course, this is
what we're gonna get.
And as for the moderators,
it's like, yeah,
you need to tell these
people to be quiet
and make sure they
control themselves,
otherwise you end
up getting Joe Biden
yelling at everybody
which that seems to
be his new thing now.
- Yeah and the candidates
they're fighting
for all the marbles right now,
because it is crunch time.
Last night, I was
watching your Twitter.
Everybody should
follow you on Twitter.
One of the things
that you talked about
was that there was
something missing.
- Sorry about that.
- No, I like the Twitter.
I want to show you this
clip from last night.
This is Tom Steyer
talking about government.
And then I want you to tell
people what you thought
was missing from the
debate last night. Watch.
- I don't believe that
a government takeover
of large parts of the
economy makes any sense
for working people
or for families.
I think that what we
need to do is to present
an alternative that includes
a vibrant competitive
private sector
but we all know, unchecked
capitalism has failed.
The answer is not
for the government
to take over the
private sector though.
The answer is for us to break
the corporate stranglehold
on our government and
have the government
work for the people again.
- Dave, what'd
you think of that?
- Well, there's nothing like
a billionaire telling me
that unchecked
capitalism has failed.
Somehow he managed
to do okay in it.
But forget about Steyer
because his appearance
is sort of pointless.
- Most people are.
- I mean, look, yeah,
you've got the socialist Bernie
and the true capitalist
Bloomberg at each other.
That's the future of this fight
but there's a couple of
things going on here.
I mean, when Steyer
and the rest of them,
when they talk about
whatever use the Democrats
believe capitalism still has,
the base doesn't
care about that.
They are socialists.
And whether you want
to call it socialist
or communist or
democratic socialists,
whatever phrase you want
to use, that's fine.
But that really is
what the base is.
So when Bloomberg
talks about building
a business successfully.
When Bloomberg by the way,
he actually wore an
American flag pin
which I didn't even
notice until afterwards
someone pointed out
because the entire thing
nobody says anything
positive about America.
Words like freedom.
Imagine if someone said
the word freedom or liberty
or anything positive about this
incredible country you have.
What they do is they
constantly tell you
how good other countries are.
So apparently
Sweden and Denmark,
it's usually Sweden
but Bernie was big on
Denmark last night,
these tiny
Scandinavian countries
with mostly homogenous
populations.
Although now that in
the last five years,
they've had immigration,
they have all sorts
of other problems,
but they use that as a
model where we in America,
we've got 350 million
some odd people
from every walk of life.
We've given more
freedom to everybody.
And somehow they can't
even seem to choke
out anything positive
about America.
And then in the few
moments where Biden
who's a little more old school,
he'll say something
about the Constitution
and you can almost
feel it in the room
that it's like Constitution?
What does that have to do
with what we're talking about?
I'm in complete agreement with
you about the pants thing.
And as you can see
here in Los Angeles,
we have been reduced to
wearing bathing suits.
It doesn't matter.
That's the point people,
we're all Americans.
It doesn't matter if you were
in a bathing suit or jeans,
it just doesn't matter.
But Greg, yes, you are right.
You are right.
When things actually
hit the fan.
When you suddenly have
real issues to deal with,
nobody cares about race,
nobody cares about sexuality
or gender or any of it.
That was one of the best
intros I've ever heard you give
because we're all
Americans right now.
We've got a real
problem to face.
And when you have real
problems, the imaginary problems
of the progressives really
disappear into nothing.
- Yeah. I'm just grateful that
you were wearing something.
- A blast from the past,
I say that only because
he was with us in 2016
for our election coverage,
when we were blasted.
That's how I came up
with that little phrase.
It's our pal, Dave Rubin.
- Oh, that's what happened?
I thought that Klavan just got
like more hair
younger and gayer.
(guys laughing)
- A little gay.
- Yeah, hold on.
- Let's just go through a
couple of things here, guys.
First off, you've left me
here with Klavan's old glass.
So can I have your glass?
'Cause I sense you're
not gonna be doing...
Let's start with that.
That's number one.
But before I do that,
I did bring my special
thicked rim election glasses.
- [Ben] Oh, the MSNBC glasses.
- Yes, because you know
a lot of times on MSNBC,
they're wearing glasses.
Now these are not real glasses.
These are prop glasses.
I actually have 20/20 vision.
But to make a point when
you were a newscaster
and as you guys are blowing up
and leaving me here in Los
Angeles and going to Nashville,
it's very exciting.
Knowles, I'm really
pissed at you.
(guys laughing)
You guys are gonna have
to do more of this.
You're gonna have to
get thick rim black,
that's not quite TV worthy.
And then when you
make a point, Ben,
and you're always making
points and then you.
- Keith Olbermann.
- Wow, that's good.
You didn't even say
anything and I believed it.
- I'm a lefty, I just did
that with my right hand.
And then you can also do this.
- [Knowles] Oh my God, I
wish you'd make a point,
'cause I'm all in.
- 100% reporting
Biden is the president.
You see, you see how I did that?
- My problem with that, I
always get mistaken for Maddow
every time I wear those
glasses and it's too much.
I don't know how to,
in Tennessee that's
not gonna work well.
In LA it worked very
well, but Tennessee,
I can't do it.
- So much of what we
hear about from the left
is exactly what "1984" is about.
So words are violence now,
but violence is not violence.
These are things
that they create
to actually make us
question everything.
And then once you
question everything,
well, then gender
is up for question.
And all of the things
that should be settled
are no longer settled.
And then what I
completely forgot about
that I found was
interesting is that
one of the things that
they're also trying
to sort of untie, that
the Ministry of Truth
is trying to untie
is the idea of time.
And it does feel like right now
that time feels a little weird.
It's partly because
of the lockdown.
Partly because we're
trapped at home,
we're all on social media,
but doesn't time feel sort
of sort of strange right now?
Like anything could
happen at any given minute
and I think that
leads to a sort of,
well, sick society
where two plus two
eventually will be five
if they just tell you.
- There are so many of
these contradictions
or absurdities that come up.
I mean the three
slogans of the party
that you always got to repeat,
they've got it on the back
of the book right here.
War is peace.
Freedom is slavery.
Ignorance is strength.
This could be the
chants of protesters
that we see marching
all around the West.
- Quite literally.
I mean, one of the things that
I talk about all the time now
is that it's the anti-racists
who are the racists now.
- Right.
- Right?
If all the people that
are running around now
proclaiming that the
rest of us are racist,
they're the ones that
are pushing racism
into society everywhere.
They're the ones that
are saying black people
should have special dorms and
that white people shouldn't
be allowed to have certain jobs
or that they shouldn't
be considered equally.
Those are racist notions.
So we live in a time where
everything has been flipped.
And for the few of us
that have a little bit
of the spark of Winston, it's
like how do you make sure
you're not one of the
people who at the end
is going two plus
two equals five?
I'm not sure.
I will tell you one other thing.
I'm actually watching the
"Handmaiden's Tale" right now,
did you watch it?
- I did, I've seen some of
it, not the whole thing.
- So I'm watching it right now.
And the parallels to "1984"
are absolutely incredible,
because this is exactly
what the main character,
June, is going through.
And it's so funny
because the show came out
a couple years ago and
everyone kept saying,
"This is what's happening
in Trump's America."
Except I'm watching
it now in the midst of
what's happening with
Black Lives Matter
and everything else.
And it's like, no,
it's all the left.
- It's this America,
the left wing.
- It's this America, it's
not Trump that's doing this.
It's the other guys
that are doing this.
So I think more
than anything else
there's a beautiful thing when
you read a work of fiction,
when you can go, holy cow,
this was not only, it must've
been true or true enough
to have made sense
when it was written.
What year was the book written?
- The book was I
guess written in 1948,
published I think in 1949.
- Okay. So 49.
I mean, think about
that, 70 plus years ago
but yet feels like
literally everything
we're going through right now.
That's an incredible
compliment to a writer
and to a work.
- And he articulates
this concept.
I mean, I think the
great one you use is
that the people who
say they're anti-racist
are the ones who are
acting in a racist way.
And the way George
Orwell describes it
is he calls it double think.
- Mm-hmm.
- So double think is this idea
that you hold two
contradictory ideas
at exactly the same time.
So you can never admit that
the ideas don't make any sense.
So for instance,
we have to get rid
of America's terrible past,
which had segregation and
the way we're gonna do that
is institute segregation.
- Through segregation.
Look, think about it this way.
What's like the hottest
book on the left right now?
It's "White Fragility."
- Yes.
- What's the subtitle
of "White Fragility"?
I don't know what it is exactly,
but in essence
it's something like
how white people can,
blah, blah, blah.
That's racist.
- Yeah.
- That in and of
itself is racist.
Forget "White Fragility."
Well, but then if you
say how white people,
the implication is all
white people are this,
whatever this is.
That is racist.
So they hold these two ideas
that are completely at
odds with each other
and they hold it because
that allows you to believe
anything basically
at any given time.
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode
playlist all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.